c'était l'hiver j'étais chez moi est
d'ordinaire je n'allume jamais la
télévision
mais ce soir-là un son strident rompit
l'espace des amis ont tablé ils mendient
regarde ce qui se passe
le lendemain je suis là bas je regarde
mais je ne comprends toujours pas le
midi au zénith prolonge sur la rue son
ombre gigantesque mais je sais pas
pourquoi j'ai envie de pleurer
j'ai peur j'avance doucement je me
rappelle le départ avec ma femme à mes
côtés il y a 20 ans rentrent en exil je
n'ai pas pu être là je n'ai pas vu ma
mère mourir je n'ai pas vu mon pays
changer je n'ai pas vu mes amis vieillir
j'arrête j'ai envie de faire demi tour
non non j'avance je marche lentement
sûrement je veux faire entendre ma voix
c'est mon devoir c'est ma liberté je
cherche quelque chose d'heureux
d'honorables comme il se doit pour une
fête bac
oui une suite de bach mon coeur bat de
plus en plus vite
j'ai peur qu'on pour mes premières
auditions le regard de l'autre me
trouble m'inquiète je suis de l'autre
côté de l'autre côté tout est pareil les
gens sont parés le monde et marie dans
une de mes mains mon violoncelle
mon autre main tendue de 20 mois
approche lentement jusqu'à effleuré sa
surface
et l'effroi
je me retourne
unia pas de chaise alors je vais vers
une maison je sonne un visage me sourit
on me reconnaît d'abord pas puis un
autre une vingtaine une foule
ma compagne sous le soleil sur les
échafaudages des gens des enfants
arian l'instant des moments en retrouver
entre là c'est dans la joie pour la
première fois de ma vie je ne veux pas
jouer pour les gens mais pour l'humanité
entière et son histoire
j'ai envie de remercier dieu d'avoir
accompli un tel miracle
je
je m'appelle misty cela frustre au
porridge et je vais jouer cette suite à
la mémoire de ceux qui sont morts pour
la liberté
non
[Applaudissements]